authors have an
obligation to make sure their paper is
based on original
never before published research
intentionally submitting or resubmitting
work for duplicate publication is
considered a breach of publishing ethics
simultaneous submission occurs when a
person submits a paper to different
publications at the same time which can
result in more than one journal
publishing that particular paper
duplicate or multiple publication occurs
when two or more papers
without full cross-reference share
essentially the same hypotheses
data discussion points and or
conclusions
this can occur in varying degrees
including literal duplication
partial but substantial duplication or
even duplication by paraphrasing
one of the main reasons duplicate
publication of original research is
considered unethical
is that it can result in inadvertent
double counting or inappropriate
weighting of the results of a single
study
which distorts the available evidence
there are certain situations in which
the publishers of two journals might
agree in advance to use the duplicate
work these include combined editorials
such as a plagiarism case involving the
two journals
clinical guidelines position statements
and translations of articles provided
that prior approval has been
granted by the first publisher and that
full and prominent disclosure of its
original source is given at the time of
submission
the main rule of thumb is that articles
submitted for publication must be
original
and must not have been submitted to any
other publication
at the time of submission authors must
disclose any details of related papers
also when in a different language
similar papers in press
and translations
the slicing of research that would form
one meaningful paper into several
different papers
is called salami publication or salami
slicing
unlike duplicate publication which
involves reporting the exact same data
in two or more publications
salami slicing involves breaking up or
segmenting a large study into two or
more publications
these segments are referred to as slices
of a study
as a general rule as long as the slices
of a broken up study share the same
hypotheses
population and methods this is not
acceptable practice
the same slice should never be published
more than once
the reason according to the u us office
of research integrity
salami slicing can result in a
distortion of the literature by leading
unsuspecting readers to believe that
data presented in each salami slice is
derived from a different subject sample
this not only skews the scientific
database but it creates repetition that
wastes readers time as well as the time
of editors and reviewers
who must handle each paper separately
further
it unfairly inflates the author's
citation record
there are instances where data from
large clinical trials and
epidemiological studies cannot be
published simultaneously
or are such that they address different
and distinct questions with multiple and
unrelated endpoints
in these cases it is legitimate to
describe important outcomes of the
studies separately
however each paper should clearly define
its hypothesis
and be presented as one section of a
much larger study
in summary duplicate publication and
salami slicing are unacceptable
practices
and should be avoided at all costs as it
can give an unfair advantage to some
scientists
by increasing the number of publications
they can list on their resume
scientists and researchers can progress
faster in their careers or receive more
funding than they actually merit
additionally salami slicing also leads
to a waste of time for readers and
reviewers as they have to go through
repetitive content
it also leads to distortion of
scientific literature
you